I got nothing I have absolutely nothing
I mean what the hell am I supposed to
say Garbage Pail Kids does the title
even Salik is gonna attempt to be a good
movie
I'd be right
I feel honest-to-god raped by this movie
it is that bad there is no talent no
effort nothing salvageable nothing
salvageable about this movie and all the
credits it's uh it's it's it's gonna
hurt I'm not gonna lie it's really going
to hurt so why waste any more time just
talking about it oh I can think of a few
reasons but let's take a gander
anyway be very afraid
first a little history Garbage Pail Kids
was actually a deck of trading cards
that children would pass around
it was obviously satirising the Cabbage
Patch Kids but these were quite
different they were gross violent and
totally disgusting so as you can imagine
there are a huge hit and kids all around
the country were passing them around at
regular then some numbnuts at MGM
thought to himself hey there's some
great potential for a really good
gripping story I don't know what you're
smoking either let's just pray you get
brain damage from it and so Garbage Pail
Kids the movie was created in the looses
form of the word cream how can they make
a film based on exciting car that has
absolutely no character story
development at all I'm still not
convinced they did but let's take a look
at what they put together anyway so it
starts off in outer space where we see a
giant space garbage can fly
what is it where did it come from what
relevance does it have on the story I
don't know it never tells us it never
fucking tells us you could still apply
rapid flowing across the screen what
make him as much sense we then cut to an
antique store in this Academy that's a
laugh
we're a garbage can begins to shake and
Rumble we then cut to a painting whose
eyes watch the can as a moves back and
forth will the movie explain to us why
the pictures eyes are moving and glowing
will be way too much granite we don't
see the owner of the antique store enter
into the work very surprised what does
that even mean we did cut to the next
day as we see a boy named doctor come
check us out not bad Dodger being chased
through the park by what looks like a
tease Jazzercise artist ah so these must
be the Garbage Pail Kids right God
they're even stranger looking than I
imagined that must be 80s mcdo style
hairspray overkill bully in a stereotype
and managed t Tarzan wow it's like the
cars are coming to LA you actually turns
out these are just bullies what's your
main character Dodger it has to deal
with which is a little strange
considering he's got to be about 12
years old and they look like they're
almost in their 20s what are they doing
going after a hypocrite whoa a whole two
dollars we can get some hardcore con
candy for that boy they can't even make
the simple act of laughing look natural
okay we're gonna see some real
breakthrough performances in this motion
picture epic so doctor goes to his job
at the antique store where he's joined
by his boss captain Menzies and suppose
they call him that because he held some
sort of command but I think it's because
he had a kid show on PBS or something
you know I can't even kangaroo only mine
is the fun doctor tries to tell them
about his bully problem but Manzini
zalman job seems to be this Hawking
motivational speeches
losing is relative my dear boy patience
is a bit of vine every single piece is a
diary of the human spirit
what matters is conceding with grace
yeah you want to get to the part we
actually help me man could settle
his differences with one of these and
some damn-fool invented gunpowder and a
bigger death will split the Atome
that's when I decided to leave mankind
to its father nobody knows how to kill
people anymore it's a lost art Roger of
course asks about the mysterious trash
can that Mazzini seems to be hiding from
it
have you ever heard of Pandora's box
according to let all the troubles in the
world were once squeezed into one tiny
little box I don't understand
think of this as Pandora's plane why
don't you just tell me what's really in
there a bunch of annoying shit someone
shut the fuck up now keep them away from
there so as Doctor continues to look
after the store one of the gang members
named tangerine comes around wearing a
leotard made out of God knows how many
dead blue leopards know how charmingly
creepy I thought he's gonna be a great
serial killer one day but the evil gang
comes back again led by their leader
simply named juice forget it wish I
could help your baby but the little
creep is gonna be taught a lesson it's a
matter of principle yeah that's pretty
bad when you're jealous of a
twelve-year-old Dodger tries to escape
but it's pulled back by one of the game
wow this is gonna be the best dad ever
but dr. Cruz he still has a few tricks
up his sleeve wall a basketball I've
never seen one of those before
does it bite you are cool but the game
grabs Dodger and takes him into the
sewer where they pour a ton of sewer
water all over it
see you later
creep do you like that took hours
thinking that oh I don't have a Harvard
education for nothing but doctors pulled
out by a group of people who look like
they just came from the Munchkinland get
it this will make my god save you buddy
yeah don't you love the way there let's
move it's not like you actually
have to close your mouth all the way is
it because all people move their lips
like this right Manzini comes back to
find that the Garbage Pail Kids are
loose and is incredibly kind enough not
to tell us where the hell they came from
[Music]
do they come from another day do they
have any personalities outside just
doing gross stuff no Chris you've broken
[Music]
are any of the not racist oh look the
dirty one just pissed his pants because
that's funny right right the correct
answer is no since you won't go back
into the pail you must at least promise
me that you will say yeah ugly ugliness
is not in a mirror ugliness is cruelty
meanness of spirit greed to be blessed
with unusual features is an adventure
he's right you know
beauty has always been in the eyes of
the beholder and anyone who has eyes can
clearly see that they are ugly as sin so
for some reason Manzini doesn't have the
right magic to get them back into the
pale which means dogger has to spend
most of his time looking after them as
Manzini tries to think of a way to get
them back in their canned prison past
hurt you can get on top of that the
better once he gets a break from the
kids doctor goes to stock that tangerine
chick who for some reason lysed dress
like she's a freakin birthday present
she test Dodger that she's off to the
dance court to sell some clothes she
designed and actually invites Dodger to
come along with her so what do we do
when we get there
what do you mean that caddie sell the
clothes well I know why does she win
tonight full answer that question what
you really just saying there total
silence until she thought up a response
so what do we do when we get there
what do you mean how do you sell the
clothes yeah boy don't ask her to play
pants weren't anytime soon so to get to
the dance court to sell her clothes when
one of the women asked her for the shirt
she's currently wearing oh my god
oops I didn't know she had boots it's
the most terrifying thing I've ever seen
why isn't somebody telling something she
has boobs
meanwhile we cut back to the Garbage
Pail Kids who just do stuff I guess
money's no problem oh how about an IOU
oh that's nice one of the kids has a
pocket knife
remember kids real beauty is on the
inside if you disagree open it perfect
so the kids ended up stealing a Pepsi
truck yeah that's a good lesson for
children as they accidentally drive over
juices car okay how the fuck you drive
over our car it's not a goddamn monster
truck why do I get the feeling Pepsi
regrets that promotion yeah where's the
story I mean did they just leave the
camera on there doing nothing absolutely
nothing that'll do it all right
this film is physically hurting me
well the only thing that even comes
close to a plot thread is that the kids
can actually sew yeah because they
really look like the sewing tight don't
they in fact they're apparently so good
at it they give dodger a jacket that
looks some ridiculous then let me even
make it as Michael Jackson's
hand-me-downs seriously only the
fashionably retarded would think this is
actual good where did you get those
clothes that was so cold I rest my case
so I guess people who dress like
Christmas gifts really dig Dodgers
fashion as tangerine suddenly sees a
business opportunity I was just thinking
maybe I could sell them for you yeah
along with mine you know that jacket
makes you look older what mrs. tangerine
you're trying to seduce me so he returns
to the shop to tell the kids how it all
went
tangerine loved the outfit uh chicks is
chicks and I know my chicks yeah I know
my chicks they have penises right the
doctor tells him that he needs more
clothes to impress tangerine the kids
agreed to make more clothes as they hop
to their female assault a actually have
a song when did they at any point
indicate that this was a musical it's
like a on top of that this song is just
horrible it sounds like a Disney baladi
but gets sodomized by a donkey hi hell I
owe this movie memo beside the fact that
their lips never sync up during the song
and that's more like choreographed
walking as opposed to dancing and I'm
the only one that finds it weird that
they're singing about working together
while they're stealing the equipment
they need the lessons in this movie are
more balanced that game of Jenga and
just to top it all off the nerdy kid
pisses his pants again oh yeah because
it was so funny the first time
hello it's morning and I have no school
home or parents to report to get that
chick oh you got his trouble I just
wanted to like me careful what you wish
for you might daddy ah words of wisdom
from Valerie balmy
thank you so much so doctor leaves to
show off the new clothes as the kids
just sit around I guess look around
[Music]
no way yeah
work no play no way down something I'm
tired of sitting around watching the
high school version of I can't believe
it's not muppets just do something
productive anything I don't care let's
go see a movie yes
watching any movie differ from the one
I'm watching now it's definitely a place
for the kids dress up in costumes as
they walk among the normal people you
know how come in movies no one can ever
see past a trench coat and fedora hat
it's it like Clark Kent's hypnotizing
glasses or something do they just make
people stupider another pissing your
pants joke cuz you know 12 times a charm
so they find some miniature ATVs because
most good antique stores have miniature
ATVs and they go to a movie theater
where they're showing Three Stooges
shorts first of all what movie theater
shows Three Stooges shorts anymore this
is in the hornies second is everyone in
this theater hi I mean I look up Three
Stooges but they're all acting like
fucking hyenas maybe they've been devoid
a real humor in this movie that even the
moderately funny stuff seems incredible
too after that they take a stop at the
toughest bar in the world that is
literally titled the tapas bar in the
world
who wrote this
[Music]
what kind of bar would operate like that
hey thank you just killed my wife ain't
my dog and crucify my mother he's got
guts for everybody so I know what you're
thinking these kids are just so charming
and irresistible surely there must be
more of them out there somewhere where
are your friends no we think they might
be locked up somewhere in a really
terrible place in the state home by the
yeah okay stay home for the ugly I can't
believe people would make a place like
wait wait
stayed home for the ugly you're doing
right I didn't want to believe that such
a place could actually exist do you
believe it now oh yes you cannot be
serious
yes apparently there's a state home for
the ugly we're men literally walk around
with net and catch your ugly people the
same way dog catchers capture puppies
for the pound shouldn't wear a mask
unless it's Halloween kids no hard
feelings okay what I mean you're telling
me there's an actual state home for the
ugly and yeah Joan Rivers Michael Moore
and carrot top are allowed to roam free
what kind of sick crazy world is this
just me we're gonna find a place settle
up partner we gonna find the home for
the ugly so yeah where the hell did this
black friend come from who the fuck
cares let's just follow it and see how
much damage it causes okay so they find
the stayed home for the ugly where they
plan to break in one night and get all
the ugly people out but it has to wait
as the other plot thread about the
designer clothes is taking places well
how do we go from a movie with no plot
line to a movie with too many plot lines
a lot more of those things for me I
thought big plans for us
[Music]
dude is she nibbling his ear you can go
to jail for that I'll be sure to tell
all my other pedophile friends how cool
you are
but it turns out tangerines heart still
belongs to juice good god tangerine
juice this isn't a cast of characters
it's a fucking grocery list
it feels lousy abandoning my principles
for money principles yeah letting the
little creep live what this guy did
Dodger kill his father or something to
me what's up with the hate I suppose I
should be dealing some drugs or robbing
some liquor stores but nah a 12 year old
with a fashion scheme that's where the
real money is oh wait a minute
I think they're gonna do another pissing
pants joke again well you know what they
say yeah at first you don't succeed try
try try try try try try try but juice
finds out about the Garbage Pail Kids
breaks into the store and sends them to
the sting home for the ugly y so that
tangerine can take credit for making all
the clothes that they made and she
displays it in her very own fashion show
you know you still need the kids to make
future clothes right so the bullies take
Dodger out back and throw them into a
dumpster to keep him out of trouble but
little did they know that clever old
Dodger could get out of the dumpster
meanwhile at the state home for the ugly
they keep the kids locked away with all
of history's hideous treasures like
Gandhi Abraham Lincoln and Santa Claus
did they ever read this out loud they're
cryin
we wanted to shut him up don't be gone
there so not only do they imprison ugly
people but they also kill them look I
know that Reagan years weren't always
perfect but somehow I just can't see him
signing off on an establishment like
this ugly people need to be destroyed
but luckily Dodger and Captain Manzini
come in to save the day I'm so glad I
can free you from this prison just so I
can entrap you again and an even smaller
garbage pail array it's even a scene
where a bunch of their biker friends
used their Harley's to rip the bars off
the window why it took out all the
guards why don't I just go through the
front door use your thoughts writers use
your thoughts so they all make it to
tangerines fashion show where they plan
to show that thief a thing or two okay
so what they're gonna do like throw
paint on the clothes cut the dresses and
the ribbons or strip them off the models
exposing their almost totally naked
bodies it's definitely for kids or what
so we then get an exciting climax which
consists of a lot of farting season and
even vomiting Wow could this be any more
enchanting
then get the final showdown between
juice and little Dodger you didn't beat
up by a twelve-year-old what did I ask
but Manzini comes in to call a little
Dodger DAP I wish my parents were
written into this movie they would know
how to comfort me so after the fashion
show is destroyed
tangerine tries to make amends with
Dodger but somehow being lied to abuse
molested and beat up Oh physically and
mentally doesn't quite do it for Dodger
anymore no thanks
I don't think you're pretty anymore Wow
I got burned by a fifth grader they
think I've had a new low
so Manzini tries to sing the kids back
into the pail with a spell he's written
but ultimately backfires
as those lovable rapscallions ride into
the night looking for more media art
thorns to destroy what a fucking load
this is it the worst the absolute worst
no story no character no plot just pain
pure concentrated pain there has never
been anything this bad in the history of
badness it should be studied and it
should be analyzed and it is I don't
know whether to give it to a scientist
to examine or a priest to exorcise I
mean it is remarkable it is absolutely
remarkable even the closing credits are
hurting me everything about this movie
is just plain alright next in fact I
don't even know why I'm still watching I
can't turn it off before anything else
oh my god oh my god
movie so bad potential is finding the
fabric of space-time
[Music]
where am I
you are inside the bad movie a film so
horrible that actually ages you even as
you wash yourself Wow yes now piss off
I'm trying to eat my process I have to
see this shit lower mass move it again
[Music]
Oh
my god it's turn me into what the movie
always was a dirty piece of crap
[Music]